入ってきてこれですねみんな知ってるかわかんないんですけどもたまたま再現ニットに
行ったら見つけて買ってきましたこちら
自らに何かがありそうなポップでございます
まあ中見るとな節にですね色んな24になっておりますとこれですねどんなものかと
いいますと
中に入れた液体が虹色になるらしいです
うぞテーマ嘘だったら良くないんですけどねでも本当にそうなるんだと思うんですけど
もすごくないですけどどういう仕組みリズム的じゃないかな
光の話を利用せた区中野行というに重要になるように設定されているのでしょう早速
入れてみようと思いますこれ本当だったら結構革命だと思うんですよ奥さんとで副虹色
の水なんて飲みたくないじゃないですか何で作った普通の日ずいぶんに
zeal になるの中でやってみたいと思ったので買ってみました同じくらいのサイズ
です入れてみましょう
本当になるのかないします
[音楽]
ん
おっ
えっうーん
ならないやーん
あっはぁそういうわー
そういうことかまあなるほどなるほどいるぞ
こんにちはを民族ドラッカーの半球面台を横から見るとただの透明なんですけどもなん
と真上から見るなー全部こうれてしまいますねそれはてみた粉ください中野水着 bg
るになっております
わかる加工わかるから本当にねさんと姉中の色変わってるんですよ
いやーすごいよこれけっこう中の運勢がで十分になってます上から見ると本当に
でのネジ色の液体になってるんですけどもこれすごいねーでまずん前に北を破ったん
ですけども
透明な水を入れると虹色になるということはこれ他の色飲み物を入れると何色になるの
でしょうかちょっとするて上手に思ったんで入れてみようと思います
政府入場まずは黄色いなずなパッと見おしっこに見間違えてしまいますデカビタ俺実は
とても美味しいんですけどは
いうとアメリカザリガニが住んでそうグリーンティーもとかな緑色が入っていますが
この黄緑色を入れるとな見るになるでしょうかまるで体に悪いろメロンソーダ
漆黒の闇小学校らーこれくらい色のせいものを入れると果たしてこの根城になるコップ
何色に変化するのでしょうか
上から見てみましょう it 上で早速入れていきましょう水を入れると
こんな感じねうは本当にすごい上からみるとマジで全部が水の色が今どのようになるの
で本当に綺麗なネジ色の液体になってしまいます
これすごくならその中にこういう色を入れるとどうなるのでしょうか
グリーンか入れてみましょう武器の木ときど
ん
[音楽]
大
あっほ
[音楽]
お茶っぽいななんかベアー
うわぁのみたくねやばい色になりますねこれこれを急いで大体そんなもんだと思いまし
た続いてでが見たいれてみましょう
黄色い缶ねどう色の変化が起きるのでしょうか
わーはいっ
まあ変わんねーなーあーでもやっぱ部分的にすぐに黄色くなったりしますね上でメロン
ソーダですはい
うーんわっっ
うわぁ逆に何にもわかんないな栄光何のすごい
まるで意味がないというのかで変化しなぽい色を入れると色が変わらなくなるという
ことか
あんまり変わってないんですよねめっちゃくちゃ緑になってしまいますね最後子が航路
先輩でてみましょう
じゃあ
彼はないのでなんだやっぱ光の屈折とか要陰謀が反射に通らなくなるのかわからない
ですけど
色が変化しなくなることが分かりましたね
ブーブ的な効果が打ち消されるんでしょうね溝家のが一番良いレーサー水を入れ
一番綺麗な虹色ができるとかはわかりました水が二重になる骨粉いいと言っているので
ぜひ買ってみたいかがでしょうかな案件じゃないんですけどねマートだけで最後にパッ
と見ねえぱっと見るとやっぱこっから見ると透明なんですけども隠してパパに水ロムロ
飲んでるわけですよ
これお墓の人の前でこうやって見せてるのを見ますって何からすごいびっくりするん
じゃないかというしょうもないことをやって強度がアップ
だろうと思います5ちゃーん
これすごくないか見てくださっ
えっいうと思って虹色の
フィッティングいできてくそ二重行きたいですか
でもすごくですねすごく色々油とか混ぜたら二重になっちゃって
設定やで絶対やだ怖い怖い怖い怖いけれどもうアクリーログとか色々な混ぜたらこんな
風になっちゃったんですよ
クリスんご無事ですかこれこういった婆さんでパンツは見えない抹茶濡れて多分一回
打ってくださいこれやばまずで本土やんでしょ
あっっ
うん水水水でも色をついてますよねはい
ぷっ
こっちに移し替えてみてください
[音楽]
えっ
うっ
ああそういうことか
はっはっはクミーチェほなをすれするッ
me
car
バッハ